hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today kicking away carbon
the unconvincing claims from FIFA and
the
and those tournament will be carbon
neutral
a bittersweet ending to cop27 in Egypt
with a deal to help the poorest country
suffering climate disasters but without
a commitment to cut carbon emissions
and a warning that despite China's
greenhouse gas emissions in Decline the
country is yet to reach its peak
[Music]
foreign
to the Daily climate show where we track
the changes to our world and interrogate
some of the potential solutions to The
Climate crisis now if you're watching
this today football might not be your
cup of tea but FIFA and the hosts of
this year's World Cup Qatar insisted the
tournament will be completely carbon
neutral a claim causing uproar and
thought by many to be extremely
misleading but what exactly is carbon
neutrality well essentially it means
taking steps to remove the equivalent
amount of CO2 to what's emitted through
activities like building stadiums by
investing in carbon sinks such as
forests and oceans that absorb CO2 now
carbon offsetting is the main method of
achieving this a way of paying for
others to reduce emissions or absorb CO2
to compensate for your own for example
by planting trees or supplying energy
efficient equipment elsewhere now Net
Zero is similar in principle but on a
much larger scale meaning all greenhouse
gases being emitted into the atmosphere
such as methane are balanced out well
our climate change and energy
correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter joins
me now I mean this is a major sporting
event is it even possible well Qatar is
insisting that it is but it is being
accused of some really creative carbon
accounting here that's why carbon market
watch was a very well respected
independent Think Tank he said it has
serious doubts about the claims just
doesn't pass the common sense test
because if you look at the scale of what
qatars had to create from scratch there
have been millions of tons of carbon
emitted so you think about seven of the
eight stadiums created from scratch all
of the new infrastructure transporting
and housing
fans and players many of whom of course
flew in with the extra emissions
associated with that now Qatar is saying
look we've got solar powered Cooling in
the in the stadiums and we recycled lots
of materials now in in the way we've
made our stadiums in particular but FIFA
is saying that the entire Enterprise is
going to create 3.6 million tons of
carbon Qatar is saying it's going to
offset a lot of that that is a deeply
problematic approach to Net Zero the
carbon Market in general is not very
well regulated in this case a fraction
of the necessary carbon credits have
been purchased a lot of them have been
purchased in renewable energy which was
going to reduce carbon emissions anyway
so there's no additionality which is a
key test of carbon credits and a lot of
the carbon credits have been purchased
not through an independent third party
which is how the vast majority of the
rest of the world does it but through an
entity created by Qatar itself now this
country is not alone in creating
millions of tons of emissions in
relation to a big sporting event it
happened in Russia the World Cup you
know in in 2018 and then in 2016 in the
Rio Olympics created 4.5 million tons of
carbon emissions but Qatar is the only
nation that has claimed carbon
neutrality and that is why it is being
so closely scrutinized and accused of
greenwashing okay Hannah thank you very
much so so interesting
um well let's take a look at some of the
days other climate news for you now
because China's greenhouse gas emissions
have been in Decline since last year
that's according to a new report that's
warned although this may seem like
positive news there could still be some
way until the country reaches its peak
well China's policies are still not
fully aligned with long-term goals to
limit temperature increases and while
the country is doing well in areas like
clean energy and electric vehicles new
research suggests it's still off track
in the coal fire powered Iron and Steel
area now the amount of palm oil being
exported out of Indonesia has risen by
10.3 percent in the last year to last
year Indonesia produced 46 million tons
of crude palm oil making it the world's
largest palm oil producer now producing
the crop contributes to global warming
and continues to be a major Drive in
deforestation in some of the most
bio-device forests around the world
now a new study has warned that more
than half of England's estuaries are
under threat of climate change now
Estuary is a bodies of water usually
found where rivers meet the sea and a
key for maintaining Wildlife such as
wading birds and acts as breeding
grounds for fish but scientists say a
combination of rising Seas Lower River
levels and man-made barriers such as
Weirs and dams are putting fresh water
habitats in estuaries at risk
okay now after hours of late night
negotiations uh the cop 27 climate
Summit finally came to an end a day
later than expected and the final
results an agreement on loss and damage
a dedicated fund to help the poorest
countries suffering the worst effects of
climate change so almost 200 countries
signed up to the landmark deal an
example is Pakistan following its recent
catastrophic flooding but there was no
agreement on cutting carbon emissions
the root cause of those climate
disasters
I'm happy that it it it it worked out
I'm happy it got gaveled that didn't get
blocked in the night or
we built guard rails we were you know we
were tents for two nights we haven't
slept so yeah it may not be the best
it's it's the beginning it's a
tremendous outcome we've been fighting
for this for three decades and the group
has been putting forward many proposals
and the world has come together I've
been very clear in my comments that I'm
disappointed we couldn't go further than
Glasgow yeah and that's something that's
being echoed by other parties
particularly climate vulnerable
countries the only way you can get us
where we need to be is by quickly
reducing emissions and that's the only
way you can stay on on the 1.5 Celsius
trajectory and I have not seen progress
on that what we have actually seen is
increased investment increased
commitment in terms of Renewables yes
there's been backsliding in terms of
fossil fuel use in response to
um to to the energy crisis
well joining me now is Nicola day Deputy
head of rathbourne green Bank
Investments and Frankie Oliver founder
of new Society ladies thank you very
much for joining us
um so you would have heard there some of
the world leaders their reaction to that
deal made in cop uh cop 27 in Egypt I
just want to get your thoughts on this
do you feel Frankie that cop went far
enough or did it fail to hit the mark in
terms of that loss and damage fund
agreed
well it's obviously excellent we have
some agreements around the loss and
damage fund but there is no
um framework around how that fund is
actually going to be administered and as
far as Corp is concerned it is failing
us as a process in terms of actually
dealing with the catastrophic
consequences of the climate crisis we
know we're near uh delivering the 1.5
outcome and I expect really that 1.5 is
no longer alive
uh Nicola be good to get your thoughts
on that because some people are saying
you know the deal was the biggest
Advance since the Paris agreement at
cop15 what do you think
well I agree certainly it was it was
very mixed it was it was good to get
that headline announcement on the loss
and damage financing it was the first
time we had financing for loss and
damage on the agenda but I agree that it
didn't go far enough you know we wanted
much more in terms of the language
regarding fossil fuels
um and also you know we do know
commitments need to really ratchet up
we've heard from the scientists over the
last two weeks who are really talking
with much more
urgency now you know we're heading for
sort of in between 2.4 and 2.8 by the
end of the century which will bring
catastrophic change so we absolutely
realized that Ambitions need to raise
enormously from here and that wasn't in
the the final text
but I do think you know it's a it's a
cop where we've seen two outcomes not
only just those headline figures but we
have seen a lot of uh collaboration on
the ground and I think that's where
we're releasing some of the positive
sides of of cop27 coming out and it's
interesting around language because that
is quite powerful but there was no in
the text at least no commitment to
phasing out fossil fuels Nicola what do
you think of that
yes there certainly wasn't the phasing
out it was still stuck to the language
of phasing down and it was only going to
fossil fuels um in that limited sort of
coal side so we didn't have the full
fossil fuels and the and the language is
still phasing down not phasing out so
definitely we don't think the language
is aggressive enough at the top and
actually you know having been at cop27
from for most of those um two weeks it
wasn't really reflecting a lot of the
language we were hearing on the ground
there is no more ambition on the ground
but these final texts they have to bring
together the consensus from nearly 200
countries it's a very hard process and I
think you know it it's important we just
keep on nudging forward and and trying
to make sure that these steps are bigger
each time at cop but but the fossil fuel
side was disappointing I agree uh
frankly I know you have a nine-year-old
for you after this cop how do you feel
about the future
well I feel deeply concerned I mean I
know that
um by the time my nine-year-old hits 20
it's more than likely that all coral
reef will be dead
um it's more than likely that the
Greenland I teach is going to collapse
which is going to cause catastrophic
floods and droughts Etc around the world
um this is going to cause food shortages
water shortages Mass migration
geopolitical risk I mean I think the
situation is absolutely horrific and I
think what we know from these
conferences I mean we have agreement
unilateral agreement from 197 countries
at Paris in 2015 and we're still
absolutely nowhere near dealing with
this climate crisis the ndc's that all
countries were asked to submit for their
27 only 24 of the 197 have actually
submitted and we've only cut the 45
admissions Target that we need to
achieve by 2030 by one percent so
everybody listening to this really needs
to take a minute and consider just how
grave a situation we are in and how
these processes are simply not tackling
the climate crisis and to both of you
very briefly then because the message
here is that we've had almost 30 years
of cop talks the next one being in Dubai
20 cop 28 are they working very briefly
Nicola
I think they're they're working from the
point of view they are an important part
of climate action they really are the
point where you have the the country's
under scrutiny to raise their Ambitions
and it's a a great environment where you
do see this collaboration on the ground
you know really initiatives being
launched between policy makers the
private the public sectors initiative
strength and collaborations formed lots
of deals done lots of knowledge sharing
and that's really the power of cop as
well as these headlines and Frankie do
you think they should continue or is
there another way of making improvements
and agreements in the future very
briefly we're running out of time
I think they do show a transparency
around where we are and I understand
that there's collaboration on the ground
and so forth but that's two weeks and we
need 52 weeks
um to really deliver the outcome that we
need year on year and we absolutely need
to be reporting back on that you know
more regularly than just every year
okay Nicola day and Frankie Oliver thank
you very much for your time and insights
today just a reminder that you can watch
Tom heat show on Saturdays and Sundays
at 3 30 in the afternoon or in the
evening at 7 30 and thanks very much for
watching today we'll be back tomorrow
with more